[Musique]
Gustavo Petro le premier président de
gauche de l'histoire de la Colombie et
maintenant bien en place au pouvoir
il devra gouverner avec un congrès très
diversifié qui a été élu en mars dernier
en vertu de l'accord de paix de 2016 il
compte 5 sénateurs et 5 députés issus de
la guérilla des phares et pour la
première fois 16 représentants des
victimes du conflit armé venus des
régions les plus affectées on les voit
ici brandissant des photos de disparu le
dernier sur la gauche des Rory Rodrigo
Tovar dont l'élection comme victime du
conflit scandalise une bonne partie de
la Colombie on veut annuler son poste
certains veulent même sa tête il est
menacé comme beaucoup de colombiens
dit-il estoy
c'est parce que son père est un des
paramilitaires les plus sanguinaires de
la Colombie Rodrigo Tovar Poupaud alias
auteur de centaines d'assassinat et de
massacres de sympathisants présumé de la
guérilla il a purgé 10 ans de prison aux
États-Unis pour trafic de drogue
maintenant il est emprisonné pour 40 ans
en Colombie pour meurtre
j'aime beaucoup mon père parce que c'est
mon père mais je ne suis pas responsable
ni juge de mon père un père qu'il n'a
jamais vu que derrière des barreaux une
quinzaine de minutes à la fois
je suis victime
je suis la première victime du conflit
armé j'avais sept ans comme mon père a
rejoint les autodéfense j'ai grandi loin
de mon père je me suis réfugié chez un
oncle qui m'a servi de père sérieux
towar on l'assassiné le 24 décembre 2009
avocat de formation a choisi ce village
d'indigène à Waco pour des raisons de
sécurité mais aussi parce qu'il est le
symbole de minorité qui ont le plus
souffert du conflit armé colombien
au cœur de la vallée de vaya terre
paramilitaire par excellence entre les
montagnes de Santa Marta et de Pereira
qui était des sanctuaires de la guérilla
valu le statut de victime depuis son
retour il a 8 ans il dit qu'il n'a
jamais cessé de militer pour les droits
des victimes et la réconciliation
nous allons montrer au pays que les
problèmes se règle par la parole la
discussion le débat et non un fusi sur
la poitrine ce sera le lac de notre
génération beaucoup de ses collègues au
Congrès ne le croient pas Louis Alberto
Albane représente les exfark il n'est
pas une victime
avec l'argent criminel de son père
toutes les affaires de son père
plus que 9 millions de victimes du
conflit je représente un territoire
abandonné par l'État mascara uniquement
qui a vécu les horribles conséquences de
la guerre dans ce pays
depuis son siège au Congrès roretto Var
dit qu'il a maintenant quatre ans pour
prouver sa sincérité et donner tort à
ses détracteurs Jean-Michel Lepas du
Canada voyez de Paris
[Musique]